so hello everyone uh
my name is anmol bhadracharya i'm a
kernel developer in wolfram research
and today i'm going to give a talk on
back testing trading strategies in
wolfram language
i'll be using um various time series uh
time series processing function to do it
so why do we need backtesting so
backtesting
can help investors and traders to test
their
trading strategies before they go live
uh
in the real time so it will help them it
could help them to determine you know if
their
uh trading strategy is profitable or not
right so uh in this talk i'll be using
financial indicators and other
time series processing functions and
historical data
of the stocks that out that will be used
for trading to do back testing
and uh before getting into back testing
i want to talk a little bit about
trading and what do we need
to trade and you know how the trade
execution works
so whenever we want to buy and sell
stocks
um through a broker um we need a
brokerage account
and through a broker uh brokers account
or broker we can get access to a
financial markets where we what we can
buy or sell stocks so we do not have
access
to uh financial markets directly right
so even if you're
trading through a trading app or through
trading apps for mobile or
you know online application or desktop
application
so you need to have a brokerage account
so
how so when you place a trade what
happens uh through a trading
app so once we uh once a trade is being
placed it goes to
uh brokers right and then brokers have
their order room
and brokers have an option to uh
send uh send your orders for the
execution to a
various market so there are mainly four
um
markets say for instance it could be
either stock exchange like uh new york
stock exchange
or uh market makers like nasdaq or if it
is a limit order
then you can also uh it can also be sent
to electronic communication network
which is basically a trading system
where uh the buyers and sellers can
their limit orders can be executed uh in
that in that platform
and the other option is going to be uh
the brokers have their own inventory
uh for uh executing the trade so they
don't need to send
send the orders to the markets for the
execution so they can just
internalize it and then educate the
order by themselves
so that's how the you know when you
place a trade
through brokers it's going to be
executed in from a high level
so whenever we want to uh place an order
uh through an app then uh what
we we need to specify a few things like
say for instance
um you have to specify a trigger symbol
on order side
you instruct the app to either buy or
sell
and you also need to specify the order
type so it could be like market order
which will execute immediately or limit
orders stop orders or stock limit orders
and you also need to specify the
quantity like you know how much you want
to buy and how much you want to sell
so that's that's sort of like a order
specification that you need to provide
so for backtesting right we need a
trading strategy
so um so what is a trading strategy and
um you know we can think of trading
strategy as just a rule
that will tell you like you know how how
much to buy and how much to sell and
when to buy and when to sell so from uh
in the simple terms you can think of
trading strategy like that so when we
want to do a back testing
so this is sort of like a process
so we will be getting a historical data
and then that historical data is uh is
going to consist of
prices it could be open high low close
and using that data we'll be computing
a technical indicators and using that
technical indicators we will be
generating buy and sell signal
and once we have a buy and sell signal
then we will generate an
order specification based on our trading
strategy
and once we have order specifications
that orders can be executed
in the market and or like in the back
testing framework
and um and once we have the order
execution
you have to update your positions and
eventually update the portfolio
portfolio value so that's how uh the
whole process of backtesting is gonna
work and that's what i'm gonna
demonstrate in this talk
so um i'm going to be using uh four
stocks uh
for uh for uh for in my portfolio so
that is going to be a zoom
peloton tesla and nvidia
and for benchmark i will use vanguard
vanguard growth index etf
and s p 500 etf and the back testing is
going to start from
january 1st 2019.
okay so let's go to another slide okay
so first we need first of all we need to
get a data right so
for together data uh we'll be using a
financial data function and
um i'll be downloading the adjusted open
high low close um data from
using financial data and for all the
tickers
symbols that is here like you know in a
portfolio and in benchmark
so this is already been downloaded and
it will return us a time series like
here when you valid zoom it is a time
series
and uh you can get you can access the
various properties that is available in
this time series by using these
properties
and uh the value dimension is five so so
when we are downloading
uh adjusted open high low close we are
uh we are uh we get like you know open
high low close and volume
all of them are adjusted and it is going
to be a multivariate uh
time series and using a path component
you can split them
into um split them into
whatever data we have downloaded using
financial data
you can also access these uh adjusted
open this information using either
meta information or using a financial
property
and to extract each components you can
either use like a path component like
this
or like i have defined a simple function
called fi
get financial property which you'll
allow which will allow you to get the
specific components by just
providing the string like this and in
this in this
and over here all i'm doing is i'm
extracting
the adjusted close price for all the
ticker symbols
and this is the graph for um uh
for so it basically shows you what
happens if you invested a dollar in each
of these stickers
and it it will tell you the evolution of
the
one dollar value over time
so uh for backtesting i need a trading
strategy and
there are like few assumptions that i'm
going to make before
doing actual processing so
first of all like you know um we will uh
so we can assume that the the account
the brokers account that we are using is
just going to be a cash account so
you will not be allowed to short sell
that is something that you do not own
you are not allowed to
sell it and you will not be able to
borrow money
from a broker to buy a stock even if you
have a bar
buying a signal so those are the two
restrictions
and um at the beginning of the back
testing uh
i will assume that we do not have any uh
positions uh so
all the positions for four stocks that
i'm using in my portfolio
is going to have a zero quantity and
transaction fee is also going to be zero
and here i'm using a daily data so it is
uh
yeah it is the daily data and for order
types uh
order types i'll be using a market order
so usually market order
is executed immediately as soon as you
place the order
and then for execution um
it is assumed that once the order is
placed
then the execution happens the next day
and
the execution price will be the adjusted
open price
and for generating the buy and sell
signal
uh i'll be using adjusted close price
from the time series
and the trading strategy is basically
going to be uh
using two moving averages which will be
used to identify the upward trend and
downward trend and whenever
the upward trend starts uh you'll be
buying
10 shares and whenever the upward
downward trend starts you'll be selling
uh 10 shares of the stock so that's how
the trading strategy is going to work
so uh before um
going into the details of like you know
how this trading strategy can be applied
to all four
uh for stocks i want to go through a
single
asset so that i can show the process so
uh here
uh i will be computing two moving
averages um
two moving averages it's going to be
simple moving average with the longer
and shorter period
and by using that uh uh indica
the time series uh i'll be using a
crossovers to identify the upward trend
and downward trend
so here all i'm doing is using a
financial indicator function
and i'm computing the time series of the
simple open
simple moving averages for shorter and
longer periods
and when you visualize this um we can
see that
this blue line or or the blue plot is a
shorter
short uh short-term moving average and
then the orange line is a long-term
moving average
and for the trend that is upward trend
we can see that the short-term uh moving
average is greater than
the long-term moving average and for a
downward trend
we can see that the short-term moving
average is
less than the long-term moving average
so this is same as like you know say for
saying
upward trend uh if we take the
difference of these two
signals or these two indicators then for
upward trend
the difference is going to be positive
and
for downward trend the difference is
going to be negative so this is exactly
what it's doing so
for up all the upward trend is going to
be above zero and then all the downward
screen is going to be uh below zero
and so the goal is to figure out like
you know what
what is the starting point right uh what
is the starting point of uh
upward trend and uh downward trend so
how do we do this
so i'm using like a time series map
function and bully to convert
uh this um this time series or this
signal into zeros and one
so once you do this uh for upward trend
you can
see the the plot is going to be like
this so here in this plot
uh all the all the values or or the
places where there is a value one
is uh is uh showing that it is it is
indicating that it is an upward trend
so here like say for instance in this in
this plot
this point here would be uh the starting
point of the upward trend right so now
how do i find
find this point using this time series
let's say uh upper train signal
so if you take a difference of this uh
time
series if you use a difference function
then you can see the plot here like this
it's going to give you
for us at this point it is going to be
one and then the other points
is going to be zero zero so here in this
time series when you plot it
um all the location or all the dates
that has value one is uh is where the
upward trend starts
and we will be ignoring the values um
that um the the values that uh that is
zero or negative one
so you can just do that by you know
using case functions and
date path and then you can extract the
dates here
and by using once you have the dates and
you have the time series for uh
for uh for the closing price then you
can just extract the values here like
that
and this is the visualization of you
know on the adjusted close price and
and the dates where you have to buy and
sell so all the things that i just
described can be put together in a
single function
called the signal crossover all you have
to do here is
uh you know you submit the uh you
provide the sort of moving average
long-term moving average and the compare
function
and it will generate the trades uh the
the dates
so now we are ready for applying this to
all the stocks so in my portfolio i have
four stocks
and i will be using the same um
uh the periods for um computing the
moving averages
so all i'm doing here is you know i'm
extracting
the adjusted close price for for for all
the ticker symbols that is present in my
portfolio
and then using financial indicators i'm
going to
compute the technical simple moving
averages for short term and long term
um all of these are uh are are in
in association form and then by using a
signal crossover
um we can generate and buy and sell
dates which are also in the form of
association
so once we have this order by order
dates and sell order dates
then we will use this information and
our trading strategy which is basically
buying
uh you know 10 shares of stocks and
selling 10 shares of stocks
and as i said like you know i'll be
using a market order to do that
so if you feed this information to this
order
generate order specification function
then it is going to give me a time
series
which uh so if you investigate this so
you can
if you look at the meta information of
this time series it is going to give me
the order date sticker
order sides and such so you can see this
information in grid nicely here
so this is so this table basically
shows you the order specification and
all the information is sorted based on
dates
and then um and then like say for
instance if you have
if you have uh buying or selling uh
if you have a multiple orders on the
same date then what's going to happen is
selling thing is going to take
precedence so selling is going to be
done first
and then buying is going to be done
later for the same date so that's
that's how the order is going to be
processed
so as i said like you know for this uh
talk i'm just using the
market order and this is the logic
for executing the market order and i'm
gonna go briefly
through this one so so at any time right
so
uh we can have a position either
positive
or or zero because we're not allowing a
short selling so we cannot have a
negative position on
on any assets so if you have a long
position
and then i have a buy or sell signal
then
say for instance if i want to buy uh you
know 10 shares then what's going to do
is i'm going to have to check my cash do
i have enough
cash to buy 10 shares of 10 shares of
stock
so if i have enough cash then yes my
order is going to be
fulfilled if i do not have enough cash
then what's going to happen is
either there's two options so either
it's going to be cancelled
or it's going to do a partial field so
like you know there's this option is
going to should be provided
in in the market order uh executing
market order
so so either so uh if
you uh specify partial order is going to
be allowed
then what's going to happen is like you
know it's going to use all the cash
to buy as much as possible as much as uh
stocks as possible right so that's how
the buying thing is going to work
and for selling uh it is going to uh
check if you have enough shares to sell
if you do have enough shares then the
order is going to be executed
if you do not have enough shares then
the order is either going to be
cancelled or partially filled
so partially field here means like you
you're just gonna sell
let's say the order is to sell 10 stocks
and you only have five
then you will be just selling five
instead of ten so that's how it's gonna
work
and when you do not have any position
and if you try to sell it
or you have a sell signal then it's not
going to do anything because like you
here you're not allowed to do short
selling but whereas if you want to buy
then you know if it's gonna the logic is
the same as i just
described earlier if you have enough
cash you're gonna
you'll be allowed to buy and if you do
not have uh enough cash then you know
either cancel or partial fuel so that's
how
the market order is going to work and
this logic
is implemented here in this
execute market order function and um
here uh for for execution price i'm
using i'll be using the adjusted open
this was discussed in the assumption
and for the execution price i'll be
using
uh yeah the open price and you you feed
that information
the buy dates and sale dates or order
specification portfolio
and you uh you you evaluate this
function and it's going to give you
a association of uh position quantity
average
cost uh transaction quantity and
cash cash value that you have so
uh so this is just going to be
association and each association is
going to be
another has a value of association
that's with the different uh key values
of the different stocks like this
so once we have this order specification
or order after we order uh after the
order is executed
then what we need to do is we need to
update the position value
uh for each stock and and as well as
like in the portfolio value
so let's say we have an asset and assets
right
and at each time uh t uh the portfolio
value would be
the amount of cash that we have and then
the position value of each assets
that we have for that time
so the position value can be uh computed
using
valuation price and uh the position so
basically
this is just the quantity of a stock
that we have so this logic is
implemented here
in update portfolio all here all you
have to do is
you have to provide how much cash you
have this can be
we can get this information from order
execution object that i just evaluated
earlier
and then position quantity is also going
to come from order execution
and for valuation i'm using the at the
state closing price
so once um we execute this
it's going to give me position value
position quantity
portfolio value humidity profit and loss
and cash
so this is the
visualization of uh the education the
back testing so here
you can see that okay you know you spend
50 000
in in that strategy for four stocks then
at the end of this year or like in two
years uh you
almost made like 25 000 dollars and this
is the cash
this is the cumulative profit and loss
and this is the position so
here uh this position value and quantity
is kind of cramped up so if you want to
uh see this individually then you can
also uh use the
spot and uh i think i used keymap
yeah keymap value to get this plot and
then you know so this is uh for
a quantitative position quantity of all
the stocks
and this visualization is a position
value for
all the stocks we have
so here uh what i'm doing
is like i'm comparing the uh my
portfolio value
with uh with benchmark say for instance
if i was
investing the same amount of money in s
p 500 etf
or vanguard uh like growth index etf
then how is uh is going to compare with
our
portfolio right so so this graph
basically shows you that and it looks
like uh
the strategy which is uh blue line or
our portfolio value is not doing very
well compared to vanguard so i forgot to
mention
in the beginning that the strategy that
i used here is just for a demonstration
purpose
so you know it's not optimal and the
parameters are not
it's parameters are also not uh used for
optimal trading strategy so just for a
demonstration purpose
so you know but you know once we have
the portfolio value you can do all kind
of
analysis risk analysis and
yeah and this is going to be this is the
profit and loss of uh our portfolio so i
think that's uh
[Music]
so that ends my talk and let me see if
there is
any questions
are these financial indicator options
um the thing is uh okay
i can make this notebook available right
now it is not uh i have not posted this
but i can make this uh
notebook available yes and
and yes the financial indicator uh
functions the options are not available
right now they are not documented i'm
just
most of these stuff are not documented
yet and still
you know there we have to do a lot of
work for coming up with the complete
back testing framework and
we are still working for it
uh are there any more questions
yeah notebook i can make it available
and i might even post a simpler version
of another notebook which which will
actually show
step by step on how how i implemented
like you know the functions like uh
because there were some time series
processing uh
manipulation i had to do for for
instance executed mark market order and
portfolio objects because the
time time frames for all the stocks were
not
the same like say for instance uh this
zoom and peloton they just started um
they just started trading i think not
too long ago i mean maybe last year but
not from january 1st for sure yep i
think that ends my talk
and if if there is any questions then
you know feel free to send it to
send an email or yeah
okay so there was a does running this
notebook require connection to any
external no it does not require any
external uh
database it's just using for financial
data it is just using the
financial data function and workflow
language and and that's it
and and for generating all these uh
signals i'm just using already built-in
time series functions in wolfram
language
okay i think that's
i think that's it thank you everyone and
stay safe
bye